[Applaudissements]
alors valérie bénaïm est-ce que vous
avez des anecdotes aujourd'hui c'est un
homme blanc je vais vous dire planoise
je vous raconte tout aujourd'hui je suis
dit il faut que tu bosses plus les
anecdotes
parce que hier je vais demander si un
mec avait déjà mis la longue avec elle
m'a dit non alors oui mais je vais pas
inventer six mois n'a pas mis la langue
il m'appelle moi jamais ahmed thami la
longue barbe à papa c'était quand on
était petit papa souviens plus non mais
harel la pathologie mais la langue quand
il vous embrasse dans l'est parce que
les gens se demandent à l'âge de cinq
secondes à l'âge de patachon lalonde les
gens twitter
non mais c'est vrai lâche de patoche
comme encore la langue ou pas hélas non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il a pas mille ans mais parce qu il a
l'air d'avoir mis nos mais ça va pas non
mais j'ai pas il est tout gris
non mais c'est vrai il est gris on
dirait en vert de gris
non mais c'est vrai n'importe quoi il
est pas prés salés les beaux gosses on
sent qu'il est malade et le poivre et
sel et il est beau gosse comme quoi si
des ophtalmos non regarde à prenez vite
rendez vous avec valérie bénaïm super
voilà ça c'est poivre et sel ça c'est
beau gosse l'élégance française et
élégance à la française
et dites moi vous êtes sorti reçoit un
petit restaurant italien a arrêté un
restaurant une manière c'est une boîte
est alors des before c'est assez un
restant ambiance et oui un peu de
musique leaf heures à 12 heures du matin
c'est ça et alors et donc vous êtes
contre à quelle heure et est-ce que vous
avez déjà vu des gens rentrent à 4h du
restaurant et n'ayant jamais remercié
veut nous faire croire qu'il ya le gars
dans le restaurant al thania 3h30 du
matin ils sortent encore des calsades
patrick veut pas très sûr on a une vue
d'ouvrir la politique c'est de là qu'est
partie la bagarre
c'est le seul gars c'est le seul gars on
y va dans des restaurants italiens des
boîtes c'est à dire quels dégâts qu'ils
lancent comme ça avec des morceaux de
pizza là tu veux pas en morceaux de
quatre fromages vins vitré vous vous
constaterez non non c'est bon c'est bon
la débauche c'est pas pour moi à eau